this video is brought to you by
brilliant problem-solving based website
and app with a hands-on approach it's
January so make a resolution to improve
your STEM skills this year a brilliant a
talk /ba graphics more on them in a bit
[Music]
everyone and their dog knows about
Russian scientist Ivan Pavlov and well
his dog and how he trained it to drool
on command at the sound of a bell his
discovery of conditioned reflexes won in
the Nobel Prize in Physiology is pretty
straightforward right well no actually
much of what we know about Pavlov's
experiment has been misrepresented and
mistranslated so well join me in today's
via graphics to learn the truth behind
Ivan Pavlov's Research mantis
fascinating life and just a word of
warning before we get started if you
happen to watch these videos with your
canine friends this is one way you might
want to cover their eyes Ivan Petrovich
Pavlov was born in roz down in the
Russian Empire about 200 miles from
Moscow on September 26 18-49 Ivan's
Father patter was a local Orthodox
parish priest well-liked and respected
figure who supplemented the family's
income by growing his own vegetables and
brewing his own vodka based fruity
liquor ivan was a frail and sickly
charles one you might immediately
assigned you the role of book 1 except
that he had absolutely no power of
concentration he hated reading and said
a pretty volatile temper
in fact he avoided homework as often as
he could preferring to help better in
tending to his plot of lands at the age
of 8 ivan suffered a bad fall plunging
from a tall fence onto a stone slab as
he struggled to recover from his
injuries his Godfather
boss er a priest stepped him for some
reason he believes that what the boy
needed was not a proper trauma
assessment or a doctor but rather
discipline discipline man's more
disciplined
so he took Ivan to his monastery where
the boy for several months lived like a
monk the therapy did produce some
results bored out of his mind Ivan
started doing something he had never
considered
reading with little other recourse the
young boy learns to enjoy it devouring
the monasteries library when he returns
home his personality had changed
he was calmer more focused and had a
great desire to learn Petra reignited
his hopes of sending Ivan to seminary to
become a new addition to the pavlov
family's roster of clergymen the other
pivotal moments in young Ivan's life was
when his uncle also a priest also names
Ivan moved in with a family if Patrick
wanted to provide his son with too
strong role models it done a pretty
rubbish job as uncle Ivan was a terrible
priest shortly after he was assigned to
his most recent church local
parishioners had started reporting
ghastly sightings of a white robed
figure stalking the graveyard bodies
would dug out from their tombs and
simply disappeared the church bells had
the habit of going off at the most
ungodly hours of the night of course it
was all thanks to uncle Ivan who enjoyed
playing a crank or two while drunk like
a baboon at a bachelor party when the
parishioners found out they cornered
uncle Ivan trashed him like a snare drum
at a napalm death recording session and
kicked him out of the village
uncle Ivan's only choice was to move in
with his brother Petter where he
apparently sobered up and developed a
strong bond with a little Ivan the boy
loved the elder Ivan from whom he heard
stories about his other uncle also a
priest also names Ivan because why
choose new names when you can confuse
amateur historians instead okay so about
uncle Ivan the second one was a good
priest
well not really his favorite pastime was
a sort of brawling much in fashion
during those days basically the men of
one street or an entire village would
fuel up on enough vodka to floor a
company of our engines then challenge a
rival team of equally intoxicated
sluggers think of this as a Russian
Donnybrook now I don't know about you
but from my experience this is not
typical behavior of priests anyhow uncle
Ivan ii once took his brawl too far and
he died as a result of his injuries
i'm not sure if such role models would
encourage young minds to take up
priesthood but these experiences surely
taught a vital lesson
to the young Ivan the importance of
moderation and the avoidance of all
excesses in life with a strong moral
compass installed by the tales of his
elder Ivan's Pavlov was finally sent to
study at Seminary his experience at the
religious school started promising li
but soon Ivan was distracted by the
irresistible allure of a demanding
mistress science during the early 1860s
Russian society had initiated a period
of economic social and cultural reforms
promoted by Tsar Alexander ii who
ascended to the throne in 1855 most
notable was the abolition of serfdom
which totally revolutionized the russian
economy and other key elements of these
reforms was the promotion of science to
foster modernization of the state as a
result local public libraries were
stocked with scientific works by both
Russian and foreign authors that were
previously unavailable rise ins public
library was flooded by Ivan and his
friends who had formed a discussion
circle to review and analyze modern
scientific discussions works like
Charles Darwin's the Origin of Species
or the journals by radical scientist to
meet troops our f1 book who would be
particularly relevance in Ivan's future
career reflexes of the brain by Ivan
session off in this book the author
argued that all human behaviors and
thoughts could be explained as a result
of machine like reflexes and reactions
young Ivan's thirst for knowledge was so
avid that he would not allow any
obstacle to come in his way if the
seminary demanded that he studied all
day he would read at night or very early
in the morning when access to the
library became so crowded that
fistfights exploded regularly he
convinced a librarian to keep a window
always open at the back so that he could
climb into a reading room undisturbed
and get on with his extracurricular
activities
[Music]
in 1869 Ivan could no longer continue
his ruse of progressing his religious
and scientific studies along parallel
tracks he had to let go of something and
that something was religion he quit the
ceremony and enrolled at the University
of some Petersburg to study chemistry
and physiology the branch of biology
that deals with the normal functions of
living organisms in that parts
Petr Pavlov was not pleased with this
decision but Ivan put his foot down he
would stand by his rational choices
regardless if these would have sour his
personal relationships in a later letter
to his future wife
Ivan compared himself to one of the
brothers karamazov from the novel by
Fyodor Dostoevsky one of the brothers
also named Ivan was a rational listent
an extreme skeptic condemned social
isolation for his near lism by 1875 Ivan
had earned a degree and doctorate from
the Imperial Medical Academy and
continued his studies under renowned
physiologists Rudolph hidin Hine and
Karl Ludovic at the same time he had
enrolled at the academy of medical
surgery where in 1879 he attained his
third degree and was awarded a gold
medal for academic results ivan studies
were crowned by his doctors thesis
published in 1883 its title was the
centrifugal nerves of the heart this
sounds like a bad Bonnie Tyler outtake
but was actually a pioneering work in
which he laid down the basic principles
of the trophic function of the nervous
system in other words the role of the
nervous system in nutrition in the means
I'm Ivan had married a teacher called
Serafima Koch AFS kaya also known as
Sarah in 1881 their first years together
though were not happy initially the
couple lives in almost complete poverty
while Ivan was still perfecting his
studies they had to frequently crash a
friend's houses or rent bug infested
attics tragically Sarah's first
pregnancy ended in a miscarriage
according to the doctors at the time
this was caused by Sarah's constant
attempts to keep up with Ivan who was
very fast Walker Ivan and Sarah soon
tried to have another child and her
chick was born shortly afterwards
unfortunately the baby boy died suddenly
while an infant despite their grief the
couple's life improved in the following
years in 1895 and received a series of
appointments which improved their
financial situation he was first invited
to direct the department of physiology
at the Institute of experimental
medicine a post that he would hold for
the next 45 years then he was hired by
the military medical academy first as a
professor of pharmacology then as a
chair of physiology all that hard work
and study had eventually paid off
they were also blessed with four healthy
children vladimir victor vishal Avadh
and Vieira with his professional and
personal life on track Ivan Pavlov
launched into the research that really
mattered to him the one on the
physiology of digestion this took place
at the Institute of experimental
medicine from 1891 in 1900 and would
make him a household name but before we
look at Pavlov's brilliant hands-on
approach to science haba you take a
hands-on approach to knowledge with
brilliance brilliance is a
problem-solving based website and zapped
with a hands-on approach they've got
over 60 interactive courses in math
science and computer science there is
the new year it's a new decade in fact
it's the perfect time for a great
resolution and whether you're a student
or a professional we're just curious
about understanding the world better
well brilliance is the place for you so
why not make that resolution improving
that knowledge just a little bit every
single day brilliant as all
are improving their platform and
recently they launched a new course on
algorithm fundamentals it starts simple
with basic drag-and-drop exercises and
in no time at all
you'll be thinking like a computer
scientist we've also recently added more
interactive contents more of the puzzles
and challenges that they're famous for
look brilliance is a great compliment to
watching educational videos like this
one and will really help you master even
complex technical subjects so if you
want to support what we're doing here at
Baia graphics and get unlimited access
to all of brilliance in depth maths and
science courses please head over to
brilliant at all /bi our graphics you
will enjoy
20% off their annual premium
subscription and let's get back to it
ok back to Ivan Pavlov and his
experiments first let's cover his
methodology
it may sound commonplace today that
science should be grounded on data
produced via experimentation but when
Pavlov emerged as a notable scientist
this wasn't necessarily a given when it
came to visi ology Pavlov was the first
physiologist in the Russian Empire to
devote himself to repeated
experimentation applying a factory-like
approach to his lab Popov recognized
that meaningful changes in the normal
functions of a living organism could be
assessed only over time
Pavlov's contemporaries would
experiments on an animal then discard it
or even kill it once the experiment was
done Pavlov instead preferred to keep
his animals alive especially dogs in
order to document physiological changes
over a longer time span he referred to
this method as chronic experiments ok so
this is the moments in the video today
when you might want to cover your dog's
ears or maybe it send them to go play
somewhere else if Pavlov's lab was a
factory then the dogs were his machines
he performed surgical operations on
every test subject opening up a fistula
along their digestive tracts a fistula
is no opening in a living organism which
allows one to observe the inner workings
of its organs Pavlov needed these
fistulas opens for two reasons number
one to observe the functioning of the
dog's digestive functions in particular
the production of gastric juices and two
to collect said secretions so
ivan pavlov may not have systematically
killed his lab animals but their
treatment wasn't exactly a walk in the
park which is I suppose what they were
probably hoping for it was a treatment
that was painful at best and caused the
death of the subjects at worst
particularly in his early experiments
Pavlov was constantly stymied by the
difficulty of keeping his subjects alive
after operating on them even if one of
his machines tragically died Ivan was
always ready to replace them but what
exactly did this factory or lab produce
Pavlov and his team cranked out
scientific papers on the physiology of
the digestive system new research
techniques and an important by-product
gastric juice litres of it Ivan Pavlov
was always strapped for research cash
and he had stumbled upon a lucrative
sidekick Russian patients suffering from
dyspepsia were ready to pay good money
for k9 gastric juice considered an
effective treatment at that time
dyspepsia is more commonly referred to
as indigestion and include symptoms such
as bloating discomfort and nausea so yes
if you're feeling nauseous and bloated
what better remedy could there be than
gulping down a nice warm glass of thick
moist pungent gastric juice freshly
harvested from a fist elated crewman dog
yep so yes there was that
so moving very swiftly on Pavlov had the
perfect setup for his indigestion
medicine factory five large dogs
selected for their voracious appetites
were harnessed on a long table each dog
was subjected to an incision of the
esophagus this opened a fistula from
which they tube led to the collection
vessel each of these dogs faced a stand
tilted to display a large bowl of minced
meat just out of reach this stimulated
the production of saliva and gastric
juices by 1904 Pavlov's side gig was
selling more than 3,000 bottles of
gastric juice per year raking in profits
that would increases labs budget by 70%
[Music]
besides capitalizing on his own brand of
furry Taylorism Pavlov began his
research of what he called psychic
secretions which sounds like something
dr. Stan's or doctor Spengler may want
to analyze too but in simple terms
psychic secretions were drool produced
by anything other than direct exposure
to food and here is where we get to
Pavlov's famous experiments just to
clarify it wasn't a single occurrence in
which he rang a bell to get a dog to
salivate as sometimes thought by modern
popular culture but it was a chronic
experiment in line with his scientific
doctrine this is how it worked
Pavlov's main research was meant to
study the salivation of dogs in response
to being FET however he soon noticed
that dogs would begin salivating when
they heard the footsteps of the
assistant who would bring him their food
Pavlov's hypothesis was that any object
or events which the dogs learned to
associate with food would trigger the
same response as food itself he started
from the idea that dogs or other complex
organisms were hardwired to respond
instinctively to certain stimuli in
other words an unconditioned stimulus
for example food will elicits an
unconditioned response or salivation
dogs will salivate in the presence of
food it's not a behavior that they need
to learn unconditioned stimulus leads to
unconditioned response Pavlov then
devised a series of experiments to
validate his initial hypothesis the
first step was to introduce a neutral
stimulus this could be a metronome or an
electronic buzzer which in a
mistranslated paper became the famous
bell the neutral stimulus did not elicit
any response
therefore neutral stimulus leads to no
conditioned response next it was time to
begin the conditioning procedure that is
associating the neutral stimulus with
the unconditioned stimulus in this
example introducing a clicking metronome
before the doc was served its chow
finally Pavlov played the metronome that
failed to produce the food I'm sure the
dogs were dead disappointed but what
mattered to the scientist was that the
clicking itself did increase the
drooling so now a conditioned stimulus
had elicited a conditioned response this
has also been described as conditional
response in
some translations of the original
Russian articles so therefore
conditioned stimulus leads Duke
conditioned response
Pavlov's experiments would become more
sophisticated for example he tried
playing rounds with specific metronome
speeds like serving food only when it
clicked at 60 beats per minute over time
his dogs became so discriminating that
they failed to salivate at any other
setting this led Pavlov to deduce that
there were colliding forces of
excitation and inhibition apply at first
a stimulus may spread broadly across the
cerebral cortex the cortex is the area
of the brain responsible for processing
and interpreting input from various
sources and maintaining cognitive
function in a second phase of selective
reinforcement the stimulus could be
concentrated on one specific spot of the
cortex
I should reinforce that Pavlov's
interest was always grounded in
physiology and in the understanding of
the digestive system however his work
did have a huge impact on the field of
psychology Pavlov's discoveries pushed
behavioral psychologists into developing
the concepts of classical conditioning
also known as Pavlovian conditioning
this is a process of learning by
association which according to
behaviorists can explain all aspects of
human psychology in the 1920s
psychologist John Watson went as far as
denying completely the existence of the
minds or consciousness believing that
individual behaviors speech patterns and
emotional responses are simply a
consequence of external stimuli which
elicit certain responses via classical
conditioning such an approach taken to
the extreme negates subjective
experience in other words 10 different
people exposed to the same input would
produce the same output interestingly
Pavlov never approved of the theories
that behaviorists had built on the back
of his experiments the Russian scientist
firmly believed in the importance of
individuals in determining their
behavior and while he as a physiologist
did not have the answers he hoped
science would one day explain it he
stated the mechanism and vital meaning
of that which most occupied man our
consciousness and its torments in 1903
at the 14th International Medical
Congress in Madrid Pavlov read a paper
on the experiments or psychology and
psychopathology of animals his research
was far from completed or exhaustive
yes his findings took the scientific
community by storm he only had to wait
one year before he was awarded the Nobel
Prize in Physiology or medicine in 1904
in recognition of his work on the
physiology of digestion through which
knowledge on vital aspects of the
subject has been transformed and
enlarged from then on the laurels piled
upon Ivan's head in 1907 he was elected
Academy ssin of the Russian Academy of
Sciences in 1912 he was given an
honorary Doctorate from Cambridge
University in 1915 he was made a member
of the French order of the Legion of
Honour this was following an lobbying
campaign by the Medical Academy of Paris
now this all takes us to just two years
before a certain events which shook the
world when the October Revolution of
1917 ousted Kerensky's governments and
Lenin rose to power Pavlov was 68 and
had been a Nobel laureate for 13 years
yet no particular sympathies for the
Tsarist regime which had been
notoriously stingy when it came to
funding research it wasn't terribly fond
of communism either and would not hide
his feelings about it
Ivan Pavlov was always vocal in his
opposition to communism and its Russian
incarnations he only had two words to
spare for Karl Marx that fool and he
wasn't any kinder to the leaders of the
Bolshevik Revolution and yet his
international standing was unassailable
and Ivan could get away with the most
outspoken and ferocious critiques of the
regime Pavlov considered communism a
doomed experiments that had turned
Russia back into a nation of serfs and
he saw Bolshevism as a system of
government that devalued culture and the
intellectual strength of a nation so how
did Lenin treat this rogue but
celebrated scientist at first Pavlov and
his family were treated like any other
Soviet citizens which means that many of
their assets were confiscated as
property of the state including the
Nobel prize money money that could have
come in handy for the tough times that
lay ahead from 1917 to 1920 the
Revolutionary Government had to defend
itself against the white armies in the
Russian Civil War a situation that
caused generalised famine and fuel
shortages for Russian citizens like most
residents of patra grants the Pavlov's
struggle to feed themselves and keep
from freezing as
at least a third of Pavlov's colleagues
at the Academy of Sciences starved or
froze to death
Pavlov barely managed to keep his family
alive like growing potatoes and other
vegetables right outside his lab and by
collecting small amounts of firewood
from a colleague by 1920 Pavlov wrote to
Lenin's secretary seeking Commission to
emigrate to Western Europe or America in
search of better living conditions and
more funding for his lab Lenin
immediately realized the negative PR
repercussions of losing the country's
most celebrated scientist he ordered
Petrograd party leaders to increase
rations for Pavlov and his family and to
make sure that it's working conditions
improved Ivan Pavlov had prevailed over
Lenin thanks to his prestige but would
he have the same luck with his successor
Joseph Stalin started his climb to
absolute power after Lenin's death in
1924 and by 1927 he had launched one of
his many purges focused on intellectuals
and scientists Pavlov was outraged
especially when restrictive measures
were aimed Jewish scientists now in his
private life Pavlov was as anti-semitic
as Stalin in his view Trotsky was a vile
yet and in 1928 Pavlov had complained to
an American College that Jews occupy
positions everywhere it's a shame that
the Russians cannot be rulers of their
own land but it is undisputed that the
scientists had a strong sense of justice
at a time when vocal descends may land
you in a gulag or shot in the back of
the hand by a secret police goon Pavlov
wrote to Stalin complaining against the
purge saying that he was ashamed to be
called a Russian we don't know
Stalin's reaction to such complaints but
we can speculate that he was not amused
luckily for Pavlov he could rely on
powerful allies Nikolai Bukharin
chairman of the common terns executive
committee considered Pavlov
indispensable and defended his case with
political remembers he stated I know
that he does not sing the Internationale
but despite all his grumbling
ideologically in his works not in his
speeches he is working for us in a case
of pragmatism triumphing over paranoia
Stalin agreed the Burin and ensured the
party would continue supporting Pavlov
the scientist and his labs continued to
prosper even in the years leading up to
Stalin's Great Purge Pavlov expanded his
operations to three laboratories
staffed with hundreds of scientists and
lab assistants was even permitted to
collaborate with scholars in Europe and
America but his relationship with the
government was never easy
apparently Moscow officials did not
understand why their big boss on out
Pavlov to spit on the Soviets this is
how it was described by ELISA B remember
valerian kuybyshev Cuba chef who is
chairman of the State Planning Committee
and said influence over government's
investment in agriculture industry and
science tried to oppose Pavlov as much
as he curds at least within the limits
of what Stalin allowed him to do
this meant that kubasov was forced
anyways to fund Pavlov's laboratories
but had no intention of ever honoring
him when a proposal was floated to
celebrate Pavlov's 80th birthday as an
affair of State Cuba Chev put his foot
down
[Music]
for a while kuybyshev successfully
prevented excessive displays of
admiration towards the Nobel laureates
but by 1934 the hostile official had
been removed from his post because well
of course that's how Stalin rolls a good
occassions who publicly celebrate the
pride of Russian science arrived on the
27th of February 1936 although I'm sure
Pavlov would have preferred to avoid it
why
well this occasion was his death Ivan
Pavlov works in his laboratory until the
very end even after contracting double
pneumonia which eventually claimed his
life the Soviet governments honored the
great scientist by organizing a grand
funeral at which a hundred thousand
mourners including party officials filed
past his casket Ivan Petrovich Pavlov
was a physiologist until his very last
day on earth and yet to the impact of
his work was felt most in psychology his
methods may not have been the most
ethical particularly when it came to art
modern standards surrounding matters
like animal cruelty more broadly the
classical conditioning theories he
spawned as well as behaviorist
psychology in general were criticized by
later generations of psychologists for
being too reductive even Pavlov did not
fully agree with strict classical
conditioning theory as it did not allow
for the individual conscience to play a
role in human behavior Pavlov's true
enduring legacy lies in the use of a
rigorous scientific method to prove the
existence of conditions and non
conditioned reflexes which provided as a
foundation for the study of acquired
human behavior and the use of positive
reinforcement in learning so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe also great way to support the
show is to support one of our fantastic
sponsors like brilliant linking to them
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]